alright people were alive on YouTube a
Monday direct message as most of you
guys know I'm gonna be doing these at
least through the duration of Corona but
may or may be may be forever the
Internet is forever on Mondays and
Wednesdays at 8:45 a.m. Pacific 11:45
a.m. Eastern this is just my way of
connecting directly to you guys getting
some questions from you just sort of
sharing what's on my mind as you may
remember for years I did the direct
message as part of the Reuben chord
episodes where I would just do you know
five straight minutes with whatever was
on my mind of the week and then in the
last year as the as the company grew
like crazy and everything that we were
doing was going wonderfully I have
actually no complaints and then I
started writing the book and everything
else we had to put that by the wayside
as we started focusing on other things
and I was also traveling a lot and
touring and everything else so anyway
this is my way of connecting directly
with you guys and it's kind of funny
there's a few things going on right now
in the world I don't know if you know
about that
but one of the things is that everybody
in television is now basically doing
what I've been doing for years although
they're not quite doing it at our level
so everybody whether it's the ladies of
the view or the folks on CNN or fox or
MSNBC or anything like that they're all
now taping their shows from home mostly
from their laptops using Skype now we've
got our whole studio here right now I'm
not letting anyone else into our house
so the only living creatures in our
house there me and David and Clyde who's
right over there and and we do have one
betta fish named John he's here too but
as of today my director Matt we bought
him a whole bunch of equipment we put a
satellite on our roof so we have
superfast internet right now and as of
today Matt is actually directing from
home so I'm using my computer for these
little live streams but when we continue
to do the show where we're gonna be
skyping and you know all the all the
usual suspects that you guys have have
come to know and we're going to do more
fan shows where we Skype a whole bunch
of you at once
and and some other cool stuff
Matt will actually be at home so we're
making sure our guys can can still work
we're trying to figure out something
with my my makeup girl Alexis and I'm
not wearing makeup people can you
believe it
because she's a contract worker and I
want to make sure she's taken care of
and I know that a million of you or
roughly 3 million of you are in similar
positions as Alexis I mean you're trying
to figure out what to do if you're a
contract worker if you were just laid
off all of that stuff and that's what I
wanted to talk about this week because
you know we can all argue about stimulus
packages and 25 million dollars to the
JFK Performing Arts Center which then
lays off the musicians like an hour
later I mean all of the endless nonsense
of how government works and one of the
things I'm enthused by at the moment is
when you see big government come in and
pour money into all of these pet
projects that have nothing to do with
helping us I think a lot of people
actually wake up to some of the ideas
that I've been talking about here which
is I'd rather you have your money hey
how about we just take less of your
money in the first place and you figure
out what to do with your life and I
think a lot of people are waking up to
that so I'm pretty I'm pretty enthused
about that but there is a lot of chaos
right now a lot of people are out of
work just this weekend I've been doing
in the Rubin Report community which I
would love for for all of you guys to
join at Rubin Report calm and we've got
the iOS app and the google play up we've
been doing a Sunday afternoon movie so
we did Groundhog Day yesterday and then
we did a giant zoom call about 80 people
were in there and we people from
literally all over the world and we
talked about what's going on and a bunch
of people were saying how they've lost
work some people were saying that you
know they've been trapped at home and
they're alone and they're getting lonely
and all sorts of things so I think
there's new ways for us to connect
there's new ways for us to help each
other and that's something that I want
to do right like I've got I've got a
platform and a voice right now so if you
are out of work if you're hurting in any
way if there's anything we can do for
you if you need food delivered to your
house like you got to contact us we will
try our best to to do what we can to
help you guys so I wanted to just give
you a couple a couple of numbers here
and by the way these live streams
they're going to be about 20 minutes
each because I don't want to bludgeon
you right like everyone's getting
slammed
with so much content you know there's
also like the way we live is changing
really I think literally by the minute
in that many people are working from
home for the first time you know these
are these are adults who are away from
their kids you know 810 hours a day who
suddenly are with their kids all the
time
one of the little things that I write
about in my book actually which still is
coming out on April 28th despite all of
this one of the things I write about is
that I think a key thing and it really
applies right now and I obviously wrote
the book well before coronavirus is
don't bring your phone in your bedroom
you're the last thing that you do at
night shouldn't be scrolling through
Twitter or reading the news and the
first thing you do in the morning
shouldn't be immediately reading the
news and compass and coronavirus ad and
CNN and fake news and data this is a bad
thing to do i we all fall trapped to it
sometimes many of us don't have alarms
anymore so we use a phone as an alarm we
actually bought an alarm like a digital
clock so I would recommend doing that
because as this is all shifting it's not
just that we're home it's not just that
we're around family more or or maybe
alone now for the first time in a long
time
you know I mean if you're if you're
single and you live alone and now you
know you had a lot of communication with
humans during the day and now you don't
have any like there's so many things
that are not the things that we really
talk about well in the public sphere we
talk about politics we talk about this
stat and this stata we talk about
numbers in economics but there is a
human thing happening here that I'm much
more interested in that that's what I
want to be focusing on so we so we have
some ways that we can actually help you
guys get get get some help if you need
it but just to rifle through a couple
numbers just so you have a sense of
what's going on here the the US
unemployment statistics as of last
Thursday jobless claims jumped to 3.2
eight million which is quadruple the
prior record so really think about that
that is the numbers that came in last
week are four times the highest
unemployment we've ever had now this we
got a major problem right like lots of
businesses are closing I just read
yesterday Kelly Carlin who's a good
friend of mine who's been on the show
she just tweeted out that Natan house
which is a deli here in in Los Angeles
like an
old-school New York style deli which is
a it's a institution 50 some odd years
it's been open that's where Larry King
does most of his breakfasts and I go
with some sometimes with his old crew
and it's just basically a bunch of old
Brooklyn 80 year olds telling jokes and
talking politics and the rest of it
they've been gone there three days a
week for probably 30 years themselves
they just closed their doors because
restaurants don't know what to do
there's a million examples of this I've
heard from some of you guys in the
community that your own restaurants have
been closing or that you're trying to
keep them open and people are afraid to
go out and the whole series of things so
so almost three point two eight million
right that's almost three and a half
million people filed for unemployment
last week which is just crazy Nathan on
our community actually had a good piece
of advice that Veterans Home vendor ins
United Home Loans is giving every
employee an extra hundred dollars to go
spend locally to support businesses that
are struggling due to the quarantine
which this idea support local if you can
it's getting trickier right because
we're all jumping to Amazon and I have
no problems with Amazon I have no
problems with big business actually I've
talked about how I believe Amazon is a
great marketplace if you sell small
products you they give you the
marketplace to find your your your your
audience right your consumers so I have
no problem with Amazon and that's great
and we've ordered a ton of stuff from
Amazon and we got Amazon stuff coming
and all that stuff however if there are
any ways that you can support local
businesses they're struggling they're
struggling more than anybody else and
many local businesses I'm sure a lot of
you know this you know they don't have a
long runway before they're just
completely you know underwater so in any
way that you can help them do that but
there's a couple interesting things
happening that businesses are doing and
this again is where it's like the
government can't do everything and it's
so funny because you know you have these
people now let's say have the entire
media establishment in half the country
that's been screaming Trump is Hitler as
supporters or Nazis evil blah blah blah
and now they're demanding the government
do things but you wouldn't want the guy
that you've been saying is Hitler the
whole time to do things so what's been
nice is we're watching that sort of
political ideology get to its fruition
right
like it doesn't make sense and I think
people are starting to understand that
as I said before but what we're also
seeing is that capitalism and private
enterprise is actually doing what it's
supposed to do which is innovating right
now so just a couple a couple things
here so Bednarik Studios which is in New
York City was about to lay off a ton of
their employees but they reconfigured
their factory to make plastic shields
for health care workers keeping everyone
employed that is a beautiful thing
bed nark studios new york city love it
nike have you heard a nike they're this
small sneaker company they are working
on making medical face shields for
frontline healthcare workers fantastic
doctors in New York teamed up with a
designer whose printing out tons of
plastic mask she loved plastic shield
masks from a 3d printer in her apartment
I mean 3d printers man there's so many
cool things we can be doing right now we
are we are actually rejiggering our
economy and the way we think about
business right now it's incredible
New Balance another little sneaker
company they're producing face masks
masks prototypes in the US a food
delivery service was just created by
restaurants that were in the process of
closing to get food to people's doors
it's called Tompkins home delivery James
Dyson you know the Dyson guy who's
always the guys obsessed with with the
you know vacuuming basically and air
things he designed a new ventilator in
ten days he's planning to make 15,000
for the pandemic fight and a business in
Brooklyn's Navy Yard went from building
large custom installations to producing
only face shields for frontline medical
workers this is just a small smattering
of examples I just wanted to give you a
couple things but there are so many cool
examples of this and by the way if you
know cool examples of this or if you're
in the business of doing these types of
things email us at contact at Reuben
report comm and I'll give you guys a
shout out we can post links to websites
all that kinds of stuff somebody sent me
an email which also made a good point
that buying gift certificates now if
you've got a little bit of money buying
gift certificates for some of your
favorite restaurants for some of your
favorite businesses even if you can't go
to them right now even if they can't
deliver right now whatever it may be but
that's a great idea it gets a little
cash in their pocket helps everybody get
through this and now you know we're
hearing that this lockdown it sounds
like he's going to go through April
at least today's March 30th oh happy
birthday to my brother Jonathan by the
way for watching stuck at home but you
know it'll be alright we'll play
PlayStation later but buying gift
certificates we've got a month now where
we most likely are not going to
restaurants we're not gonna be doing a
lot of stuff but if you can get a little
money into these companies pockets
hopefully that gets them through the
through the hump here gets them over the
hump and then we can we can go from
there
oh this is this is a really important
one so a ton of you that are saying that
you've lost your job you don't know what
to do there are companies that are
hiring you just have to know who they
are so let's just give you a list right
now Amazon is hiring a hundred thousand
new workers and it's gonna raise the pay
of its current workforce okay good for
you Amazon we like that
Kroger supermarkets is hiring right now
I know that in there's a couple of them
in Jersey that are hiring for sure but I
think they're there nationwide Philips
is hiring Unilever is hiring
instacart is hiring Facebook is hiring
Wells Fargo is hiring Squarespace is
hiring United Healthcare Group is hire
and Charles Schwab is hiring spectrum is
hiring hiring usajobs.gov those those
are just a couple and I'll throw in a
little bit more the Rubin report was
hiring till last week but we just
brought on our new associate producer
Michael who just started on Monday so
welcome aboard Michael and and my other
company locals which built Rubin report
comm and we're building digital homes
for creators we are hiring developers
right now so if you're interested if
you're a developer and you're a software
guy you can email jobs at locals comm
and obviously you can be anywhere in the
country quite literally you could be
anywhere in the world and we're
interested so there's there's a lot
going on here guys
and I think we can help each other let's
figure out ways to do it let me jump in
take a couple couple questions from the
Rubin report community by the way
yesterday's movie was Groundhog Day so
we've been doing this every Sunday at 1
p.m. Pacific 4 p.m. Eastern we watch a
movie so we did we did contact was the
first one we did idiocracy two weeks ago
we did Groundhog Day yesterday and
Groundhog Day I'm sure most of you have
seen it's just a
wonderful Bill Murray movie and it's
it's it's it's a it's Jordan Peterson's
favorite comedy because it's just such a
wonderful example of how you're supposed
to live life like each moment trying to
get better better yourself not to
manipulate people not to get more out of
the world but to actually find yourself
true worth true purpose true happiness
and that's the story that Bill Murray
has to go through throughout the movie
so we watch that and we did to this big
zoom call with about about 80 people it
was pretty awesome so I hope you guys
will join us over there but so we're
taking we're taking questions from their
engineering politics says what changes
do you think will become permanent after
this crisis is over I'm speaking I'm
speaking more specifically in terms of
work situations what will change
permanently for the Rubin report
employees and workflows so from the
Rubin report side as I just mentioned I
mean my director Matt is now working
remotely we bought him all this
equipment that he can now direct the
show meaning he can do camera cuts
directly and editing or remotely and the
rest of it so you know maybe in the
future depending what's going on we'll
be doing more Skype and remote things I
mean I love the live interview and I
hope I'm able to be within six feet of
other humans soon enough but we now have
great flexibility in that regard so
that's that's actually nice I don't know
maybe we'll do more shows on the road
you know like maybe there's all sorts of
interesting things I think the key thing
now is that we all need to make sure
that the internet doesn't collapse on us
and we don't get you know bottle necked
and log jammed on the internet because
the LA Internet here has been pretty
absolutely horrible so we had to make a
major investment last week and as I said
we now at the satellite for this
supposedly it's like direct Internet
it's just ours
where you know when you're on spectrum
or the other stuff you know you're
sharing internet with a lot of people so
even when they tell you you're getting
oh you're getting 500 megabytes download
you're not necessarily actually getting
that so now we have this direct internet
thing so my video should look pretty
freakin smooth and clear to you if it
doesn't there is going to be hell to pay
so that's just in terms of the Rubin
report I mean look we're gonna we're
gonna keep doing live stuff I think as I
said it's like we right now I have a
home studio we can do whatever we want
like I don't know at this point it's
like we should probably
have a television show out of here
everybody else is on skype you know it's
not it's not even that I'm so interested
in doing television per se but I think
you know we're as you watched the the
CNN people now do their thing from home
it's like most of the nobody really
cares about these people anyway what
people cared about was that they were
part of this CNN network and people
think back to CNN as if it was like you
know 1990-91 in the Gulf War as if CNN
means something but now when you just
see that oh these are just people
sitting at home and how do they get
their information via Twitter and you
know wherever else it's like they're no
better than anybody else and I think
that's gonna become increasingly obvious
so this this thing where the mainstream
media has been collapsing an alternative
media has been rising I think you know
we've been at this sort of parity thing
for a while and I think it's been going
like this but I think we're gonna see a
major rise in this because the the giant
networks the overhead it takes the money
it takes to do all this stuff I mean
think about it just think about it this
way if you've gotten any worth out of
this you know I've been talking for
about 18 minutes so I got it I got to
finish up here quick but you know this
we can do this slim and trim from my
home clad you want to come over here and
say hi everybody he's just staring at me
okay we can do it slim and trim with
low-cost and I can get you I think I've
given you some valuable information and
hopefully you guys will jump in the
comment section and everything else and
share information with each other and
all that watch CNN tonight I mean it
cost them you know hundreds of thousands
of dollars to do episodes it's a
tremendous amount of waste and you're
not really getting information you're
getting things that'll just keep you in
the political fight all the time all
right a couple others real quick Kevin
asks what's your go-to stress relief
strategy you know what one of the things
that I find really important is you have
to have a cut off from the news and the
mania of everything so I really try you
know it's like you know we usually have
dinner something around 7:30 or so and
then after dinner it's like I really try
not to be on my devices at that point
you know it's like I'm just trying to
we've been watching The Sopranos
actually it's what we're doing we just
finished season one we're in season two
now David's actually never seen The
Sopranos before and I missed the first
two seasons so I'm absolutely loving and
I mean it's true it's like
filmmaking true alright now there's
quite little you want to get your nose
in here go down on the camera a little
bit I want to say hi Clyde all right
there we go oh you guys I love this so
I'm walking down the street yesterday
I'm walking with Clyde and you know
everybody's on lockdown and this I this
guy yells he goes Dave Rubin Dave Rubin
and Clyde Clyde I Love You Man Clyde I
love you and it turns out that it my
neighbor saw me on Dana Perino with
Clyde the other day and he was more into
Clyde than me but then in the weirdest
twist he's telling me oh you know he
watches Dana all the time he loves her
and then he's like oh yeah and I grew up
in the same town as you I grew up in
Syosset Long Island though and it turns
out we went to the same the same middle
school and in high school so we chatted
for a while and he was a big record
executive so anyway I even mentioned
this more because it's like get out
there take some walks you know I'm
finding the dog walking people are still
connecting with humans you know what I
mean we can still let the dog sniff and
keep our keep our six feet but I'm
seeing more and more people take walks
you know I'm seeing a lot of kids on
skateboards and all kinds of stuff so
just keep trying to figure out how to
have those connections however you can
so for me it's about having some sort of
sensible cutoff time and I fail at it
sometimes you know what I mean and then
suddenly or commercial if I'm watching
regular to be a commercial come on I
jump on my phone and I just think
controlling some of that stuff will be
really good for you guys
I also think a very I know this is gonna
sound crazy but a very simple thing to
do in the morning is when you get up I
usually get up I open the door so Clyde
can pee and then before I do anything I
just have a glass of water and I
actually think there's some value in
that I don't know if it's just like
actually like the gulping of it or just
like the calming feeling or your body
needs a little h2o to get you going but
there's something about the reset that I
like there okay let me do one more
people whose work this is max justice
people whose work depends on large
crowds like concerts convention sporting
events are pretty much over until viable
treatment or cure is implemented I'm a
jib operator and drone operator and it's
time to adapt or die
any thoughts on Lynn lark large crowds
will be acceptable good man you know
speaking of jib operators first off I
have huge appreciation for you guys
because the jib is not easy to move it
is work I've known many jib guys and you
know you beget you get back pain and all
sorts of stuff so first off I hope your
hope you're doing all right
you're probably enjoying a little bit of
a break actually
well look we don't know I just found out
so we do know this for sure so our tour
was supposed to spark start on April
28th in New York as I said the book is
still coming out on April 20th but the
tour obviously has been totally
postponed we know we're on national
lockdown now through April 30th so that
is a month from today so you know we've
been doing this for about three weeks
already so you know we're looking at a
two-month situation here and then
hopefully it ends at April 30th but
we'll see but we don't know when the
events are gonna come again I talked to
my whole team and it's like we're trying
to figure out when we can reschedule
things and all that I mean everybody's
in limbo so nothing's moving what I do
hope though and I genuinely don't mean
this just for me I mean this for
everybody is that when we get past this
thing and we can start being out there
again and and going out I hope we really
all do it I hope that we don't have this
residual fear a residual unwarranted
fear as long as it is unwarranted and I
will go out I will tour as many cities
as I can if I have to be out on the road
for a year I will do it I miss
connecting with you guys I really do you
know a friend of mine messaged me
something that was interesting he's
single he lives in New York City and he
said he said Dave you know I haven't
touched anyone for about twenty days and
he meant just like hug somebody or shake
somebody's hand or something like that
he said I have an invisible contact you
know in weeks I thought that's really
that's really interesting like just the
idea that you know it's important to
like actually reach out and touch
another human is is important so there's
so many things going on right now but
anyway I really do hope and I think what
will happen actually is there will be a
renaissance after this knocking about
last week I think everyone I know you
person watching this right now I just
know you're thinking about the world in
a different way we're all thinking whoa
who are all the systems we had before
this adequate do I have the right job do
I suddenly like working from home are
the people that I'm trapped in my house
with do I like these people do I want to
be with these people I mean I think
there's there's so many things we're all
thinking about right now am I wasting my
life at some job I don't like you know
like all of that stuff should I be
working out more should I be eating
healthier one of
we're really trying to do is we're
conserving as much food as possible so
normally I make a French press full of
coffee every morning and then I you know
I have my cup and a half or something
and I usually spill out the rest I'm now
putting it into a glass jar put it in
the fridge and then I have that the next
day so we're doing that we're taking you
know the butts of onions and growing new
onions that I'm planting on the side of
the house we started doing it with
romaine lettuce you can cut it put it in
a little water and start growing romaine
from romaine whose incredible science
it's amazing right so there's lots and
lots of stuff that we can all do
okay I'm gonna wrap this up though
because we want to keep these somewhat
short but remember every Monday and
Wednesday 8:45 a.m. Pacific 11:45 a.m.
Eastern and if you want to submit
questions or just be part of what we're
really growing as just I really think a
great community where we're helping each
other out and we're talking through it
and we're sharing food we're sharing
recipes we're sharing music all sorts of
stuff join us at Ruben report.com
and and just let us know what's going on
with you and how we can help and all
that good stuff and I hope you all have
a great day and you know just keep on
keeping on all right